l'article 30 le 514 de monsieur ozu
llose merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre l'objectif de cet
amendement et l'abrogation des
dispositions de la législation locale
sur les cultes et uniquement
l'abrogation des législations locales
sur les cultes il y a bien évidemment
dans le droit local d'alsace-moselle des
dispositions sociales qui sont très
intéressante et que nous aimerions voir
étendu à l'ensemble du territoire
national il a été question à plusieurs
reprises ici dans cet hémicycle d'un
sondage publié par par un journal
j'aimerais en donne hélas la totalité
pour l'abrogation du concordat 78% des
français sont favorables pour
l'abrogation du concordat 52% des
alsaciens et des mouvements sont
favorables sur le financement du régime
concordataire 83% des français
considèrent que ce n'est pas normal en
alsace-moselle 53 % des habitants ne
trouve que c'est pas normal
et ensuite et ce qui est très
intéressant sur le principe d'un
financement public des cultes les
français de l'intérieur comme vous dites
ils sont opposés à 67%
mais les alsaciens et mosellans y sont
favorables ils sont favorables au
financement du culte à 56 % ce qui
montre bien qu'il ya un rejet du
concordat dans sa forme actuelle et
chers collègues
contrairement à la guyane contrairement
la guyane où le le statut de l'ordonance
2828 leur a été imposée par la force
sans que jamais jamais les guyanais
donnent leur avis au contraire au
contraire et je tiens à le reconnaître
les alsaciens et les mosellans par leur
représentation nationale et par deux
fois en 1924 et en 1946 ont montré leur
attachement concordat et je pense que ça
nous oblige un débat local qui doit
avoir lieu en alsace et en moselle jeu
je suis tout à fait d'accord mais engagé
engager ce débat parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les choses doivent bouger
et par exemple les cultes chrétiens ont
reconnu dans un article du 17 mars 2004
qu' il fallait nécessairement ouvrir le
concordat à d'autres cultes et notamment
il prône l'admission du culte musulman
je les cite à la table de la république
donc il est temps de réfléchir sur le
concordat merci monsieur le président
merci je précise tout de suite que je
suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe crc e sur cet
amendement avis la commission madame le
rapporteur défavorable nous l'avons déjà
dit pour les outre-mer il y à des
équilibres vous le dites vous-même
d'ailleurs c'est à aux alsaciens
mosellans de faire ce travail donc
défavorable à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
défavorable je suis donc saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public à monsieur ozu
liesse un petit mot monsieur le
président si vous me permettez monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues dans une
tribune publiée par la croix la suite de
ce sondage le 9 avril 2021
la députée européenne et les trois buts
et les trois députés du bas-rhin
écrivent la possibilité de financement
public d'un lieu de culte a le mérite de
créer les conditions pour une adhésion
des cultes aux principes républicains
permettez moi de citer l'excellente et
études de hakim el karaoui et benjamin
au dail et qui vient de paraître sur les
militants
du jihad c'est une étude financée par
par l'institut montaigne je pense que ça
devrait vous satisfaire
en france les 508 jihadistes donc ceux
qui ont basculé dans la lutte armée pour
lesquels la commune d'origine et connus
viennent de 150 villes différentes
mais principalement des grandes villes
et par ordre
ils viennent principalement de toulouse
strasbourg strasbourg nice et paris ce
que je veux vous montrer par là c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de coïncidence entre les
formes donnée à la gestion des cultes
voire même l'enseignement du religieux
et les actes djihadistes les actes aux
djihadistes hobbies ou obéissent à
d'autres logiques et vous n'arriverez
pas à contrer le djihadisme en changeant
les formes les formes du culte c'est
malheureusement ce que nous essayons de
vous faire comprendre par rapport à
cette loi les causes elles sont liées et
l'étude le montrait bien il ya
aujourd'hui 30 à 40 quartier qui sont en
situation très difficile et qui est d'où
viennent l'essentiel déjà nice si vous
voulez combattre ce radicalisme ce qu'il
faut c'est une politique de la ville ce
qu'il faut c'est intervenir dans les 30
à 40 quartier qui aujourd'hui produisent
l'essentiel de cette radicale à sion de
cette radicale de ce radicalisme de ce
fanatisme et je pense que ce sera
beaucoup plus efficace que transformer
le statut des cultes comme vous nous
proposez merci monsieur le président
allez j'ai une série de demandes
d'interventions donc on commence
monsieur fernique
oui merci monsieur le président le
groupe écologiste ne peut approuver une
telle proposition expéditive
d'abrogation qui toucherait près de 3
millions de nos concitoyens
il n'y a pas eu de larges débats de
vaste concertation sur la question et ce
récent sondage a montré combien la
confusion et les polémiques du jour
chamboule l'opinion sur ces questions je
crois que ce sujet est trop lourd pour
se positionner dans la précipitation
pour proposer peut-être des évolutions
120 travail approfondi des coudes
d'analysé de dialogue
d'où l'abstention mon groupe pour ma
part comme élus d'alsace je voterai
contre cet amendement avec cinq
arguments
l'argument de combat
de compensation ce droit particulier le
fruit déchirure cette différenciation et
la compensation d'une rupture historique
comme le droit particulier de la corse
compense une disparité géographique
on ne peut pas plus effacer l'histoire
qu'ils ignoraient la géographie
l'argument européens si le régime des
cultes reconnus déconcerte parfois les
autres français il est largement partagé
dans une europe très familière de ce
principe de reconnaissance des cultes
instituée l'argument constitutionnel le
conseil constitutionnel a tranché le
droit des religions d'alsace moselle est
conforme à la constitution
compatible avec le principe de laïcité
l'argument déquilibre la france on l'a
vu soutien des aumôneries accepte les
droits particuliers des cultes outre-mer
partout elle concilie deux principes
républicains la laïcité et la liberté
religieuse en alsace moselle
l'équilibré est différent mais tout
aussi intelligent enfin l'argument de la
concorde
la pratique a évidemment bougé depuis
bonaparte nous n'en sommes plus au
régime donnant donnant
la subvention d'état contre le contrôle
politique des cultes nous avons un
nouveau rapport entre les pouvoirs
publics de plus en plus décentralisée et
les cultes acteurs de l'espace public
par leur engagement social caritatif
interreligieux et cela participe à
l'amélioration du vivre ensemble
cet argument d'ailleurs un site au nom
de l'égalité peut-être à une évolution
pour élargir progressivement le groupe
des quatre cultes statutaire à l'islam
peut-être à l'islam pardon peut-être
d'abord dans le domaine scolaire pour
l'éveil culturel et religieux ou encore
pour la formation des ministres du culte
dans le cadre universitaire locale
merci madame schalk monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
c'est sans hésitation en tant qu'élu
d'alsace que je voterai contre
l'amendement du groupe communiste visant
à supprimer d'un trait le régime
concordataire en alsace moselle
d'une part parce que je suis
profondément attaché au régime
spécifique des cultes en alsace moselle
je ne suis pas la seule le conseil
d'état dès 1925 les constituants de 1946
et de 1958 le conseil constitutionnel
en 2013 ont reconnu la pertinence du
régime local et son inscription pleine
et entière dans l'histoire de notre
république
par ailleurs une grande majorité
d'alsaciens et de mosellans sont
attachés au concordat et ce n'est pas un
sondage qui est à prendre en compte
depuis 1801 date de la signature du
concordat par la france napoléonienne le
régime local des cultes a su traverser
les siècles et fait désormais ses deux
cent vingt ans d'existence
il n'a rien de transitoire comme la
musique d'ailleurs de manière erronée
l'amendement qui nous est soumis je suis
également contre cet amendement car le
régime local des cultes fait partie
intégrante de l'identité alsacienne et
mosellane il a d'ailleurs porter de
beaux fruits
à commencer par deux facultés de
théologie l'une catholique l'autre
protestante qui contribue au rayonnement
de l'université de strasbourg
il a également su créer les conditions
d'un équilibre et d'un dialogue apaisé
d'une harmonie qu'il ne faut en aucun
cas rompre il permet le dialogue entre
les religions et les pouvoirs publics
il encourage le dialogue inter religieux
dont j'ai pu mesurer toute l'importance
et la pertinence
en tant qu'élu régionales je voudrais
également contre cet amendement
parce qu'ici au sénat chambre des
collectivités territoriales nous savons
et connaissons toute l'importance des
spécificités locales
notre pays est riche de ses territoires
de leur histoire de leur culture de
leurs spécificités
ce sont autant de spécificités qu'il ne
faut pas abrogée qu'il ne faut pas
craindre mais bien au contraire qu'il
nous faut protéger et consolider
précisément le système concordataire en
alsace-moselle constitue l'une de ses
spécificités emprunt de l'histoire si
douloureuse et particulière de notre
région
mes chers collègues il n'y a aucune
opposition entre concordat et laïcité
bien au contraire il s'agit d'une
précieuse complémentarité dans le total
respect de l'article 1er de la
constitution selon laquelle la france
est une république laïque je vous
remercie
merci
sur richard merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
serais pas étonné si le sénateur
alsacien que je suis se déclare aussi
totalement opposé à cet amendement
il a effectivement indiqué dans l'exposé
des motifs de cet amendement je cite que
la loi de 1905 de séparation des églises
et de l'état doit être appliquée dans
l'ensemble du territoire et donc que le
régime concordataire d'alsace moselle
n'a pas sa place c'est les termes dans
notre république laïque permettrait de
dire que cette double affirmation est
juridiquement fausse ça vient d'être dit
le conseil constitutionnel à tout le
moins a jugé que le droit local alsacien
mosellan qui comporte le concordat est
un principe fondamental reconnu par les
lois de la république
cette double affirmation s'inscrit
d'ailleurs pas non plus dans l'air du
temps
si j'en crois les récentes prises de
position du conseil d'état qui reconnaît
le droit à la différenciation et je
crois savoir que nous allons être saisie
prochainement d'un projet de loi 4d
notamment indé comme différenciation
dont le parlement espèrent être saisi un
jour mais sur le fond pourquoi faudrait
si les supprimer je m'adresse à monsieur
le comte
pourquoi faudrait-il et supprimé les
dispositions concordataire en alsace
moselle
mes chers collègues et tout
particulièrement du sérieux le concordat
est pour nous un cadre de réflexion et
de relations claires qui fassi qui
facilite le dialogue entre les cultes et
les pouvoirs publics
faut-il vraiment laissé les cultes
s'autogérer son qu'aucune garantie
puisse être exigé des pouvoirs publics
faire comme si les cultes n'existait pas
n'est ce pas le meilleur moyen d'amener
ces cultes à faire comme si la
république n'existait pas je voudrais
d'ailleurs juste te répondre à monsieur
ou julia c'est lui dire que les
alsaciens mosellans
même si effectivement ça s'est effritée
à travers le temps pour cause de
subventionnement à une mosquée tout
récentes sont très attachés à leur droit
local y incluant le concordat et en ce
qui concerne le concordat seul à la
première question suivant de l'étude
ifop dont vous avez parlé
leurs collègues êtes vous favorable ou
opposé à ce que dans certains
territoires français les ministres des
cultes et les édifices religieux il soit
financé sur des fonds publics
56% des alsaciens mosellans répondent
qu'ils y sont favorables
67% des français disent qu'ils y sont
des femmes c'est nous c'est juste
l'inversé
alors pour nous mes chers collègues la
laïcité n'est pas une interdiction faite
aux mondes politiques de réfléchir avec
les cultes aux choses spirituelles
il faut s'opposer à cet amendement
journée merci monsieur kern
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre naturellement en tant que
sénateur alsacien je ne je ne devais de
prendre la parole mais comme pour vous
faire gagner du temps et que mes trois
collègues précédents ont développé tous
les argumentaires
c'est à dire que je voterai contre cet
amendement et que je me rallie à ses
argumentaires monsieur hervé
merci monsieur le président monsieur
richard collègues fallait bien qu'un
français de l'intérieur prenne la parole
pour lui aussi de dire combien il est
opposé à cet amendement d'abord pour
vous dire que si on reprend l'histoire
le concordat en soi n'est pas une faveur
faite à l'église aux églises
protestantes ou encore au culte
israélites
en aucun cas le concordat de bonaparte
c'est une manière de faire rentrer les
guide dans une organisation et de la
contraindre
quelque part c'est une préfiguration de
ce qui va se passer quelques années plus
tard avec un loi de 1905
donc ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième chose c'est que dans notre
débat pendant tout le texte
on a un paradoxe c'est qu'on veut quand
même à bien des égards mettre le nez
dans les affaires religieuses m 2 le nez
dans les affaires du culte et que si la
laïcité tel que on l'exprimé en france
nous l'interdît peut-être que le modèle
concordataire est un mauvais modèle
intéressant parce qu'il permet aussi
d'avoir une relation de nature
différente et moi je trouve que qu'il
s'agisse des territoires d'outre-mer com
qu'il s'agisse des deux départements
d'alsace et de la moselle qu'on veuille
gommer l'histoire qu'on veut et gommer
les spécificités locales moi ça me
choque profondément
et dans un pays qui proclame la laïcité
qu'il met dans les premiers articles de
la constitution et qui arrive à trouver
des modalités différencier d'un
territoire out c'est quelque chose qui
moi me
me séduit plus tôt et je trouve ça
plutôt un temps plutôt qu'une volonté
totalement unique une vision unique sur
l'ensemble du territoire et enfin
monsieur mini cyr matin j'écoutais une
émission musulmane sur france 2
le vers 9 heures du matin et un
chercheur expliqué que la france est
sans doute le pays d'europe qui roule ya
la plus grande contradiction entre les
principes évoqués la réalité de terrain
et c'est j'en veux dire par là c'est
qu'il ya pas mal de pays où le
catholicisme par exemple rouleau ou la
religion anglicane pour parler de nos
voisins britanniques sondés religion
d'état mais dans l'aide dans lesquelles
l'état intervient beaucoup moins que
nous en france merci j'ai été saisi
d'une demande au scrutin public par le
auxerre c e et le groupe l'est
républicain sur l'amendement 514 je vous
rappelle que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable l'avis du gouvernement est
défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
sur la maintenance 514 compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs groupes
politiques et notifié la présidence
nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 265 pour l'adoption
24 contre 241
le sénat n'a pas adopté et nous passons
à l'article 31 ou je suis saisi de
plusieurs demandes de parole monsieur
ouzoulias ce monsieur ouzoulias ce
pardon monsieur le président j'ai été
emporté par mon allégations monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous venons
de parler du concordat mais à côté il ya
le code civil local qui gère le statut d
association
aujourd'hui il ya trois types de statuts
les associations non inscrits
les associations inscrites de droit
local sur lequel il ya un double
contrôle par la justice et par la
préfecture et enfin les associations
inscrites dont la mission a été reconnue
d'utilité publique
il faut pour ça qu'elles aient un
caractère philanthropique éducatif
scientifique social familial ou
culturelles et je vous pose la question
monsieur le ministre
est ce que le cultuel pourrait rentrer
aussi dans cette mission reconnue
d'utilité publique à ces trois statues
vous en ajoutez par la présente loi
une quatrième ce sont les associations
inscrites à objets cultuels et c'est une
transformation majeure du droit local
d'alsace moselle que vous allez accepter
chers collègues n'en doute pas un
instant nous nous voterons contre à
propos de la constitutionnalité du droit
local
je voudrais vous rappeler précisément la
décision du conseil constitutionnel dit
somodia le conseil constitutionnel dit à
défaut de leur abrogation ou de leur
harmonisation avec le droit commun ces
dispositions particulières ne peuvent
être aménagées que dans la mesure où les
différences de traitement qui en résulte
ne sont pas accrue et que leur champ
d'application n'est pas élargie je pense
qu'il il reviendra au conseil
constitutionnel de nous dire si la
création dans le droit local d'alsace
moselle en des associations inscrites à
objet culturel correspond exactement à
la décision de ce mode ya ce que nous
regrettons sur sur ce texte et qu'il
aurait été beaucoup plus simple de
prendre les assauts de le statut d
association loi de 1905 t que tel que
vous venez de le changer par la présente
loi et les appliquer à toutes les
associations cultuelles alsace modèle
plutôt que de rédiger un indice positif
qui change complètement la nature du
droit local
enfin j'aimerais remarquer pour finir
que ces nouvelles associations de droit
local ne dispose pas de tous les
avantages fiscaux consentis aux
associations cultuelles loi de 1905
donc il ya une différence de traitement
qui perdure merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur richard merci monsieur le
président sur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet article 31 concerne
l'application des dispositions de ce
projet de loi
confortant le respect des principes de
la république alsace moselle
à cet égard je voudrais d'abord
remercier sincèrement monsieur le
ministre gérald darmanin d'avoir accepté
de faire
rires ont durant propre je vais dire
c'est les mesures concernées
respectivement dans le code civil local
et le code pénal locales et de ne pas
avoir procédé à une simple référence à
la loi de 1905 dans les codes concernés
ce faisant monsieur le ministre vous
avez éviter toute confusion tout risque
de confusion pour l'avenir entre les
textes de droit général et textes de
leur local de droit local et j'y vois
clairement monsieur le ministre
une marque de respect de votre part à
l'égard de notre droit local je le
répète
soyez en remerciés pour autant si l'on
peut être d'accord avec l'application
aux trois départements de l'est de
dispositions nationales visant à lutter
contre le séparatisme
certaines modifications s'avèrent
souhaitable afin de tenir compte encore
mieux de la spécificité du droit local
elle donne lieu à plusieurs amendements
dont vous noterez monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues qu'ils viennent de
sénateur alsacien mosellan de la
quasi-totalité des bandes notre
assemblée
je vous invite donc mes chers collègues
à faire droit à ces différentes demandes
d'amendements enfin puisque certains
s'interrogeant l'a vu tout à l'heure sur
l'opportunité de conserver le
particularisme alsaciens qui me soit
permis d'utiliser cette tribune pour
dire que s'il a été possible à la ville
de strasbourg de décider de verser une
subvention à l'association milli gorus
pour la construction de la plus grande
mosquée d'europe
cette décision n'a rien à voir avec le
régime concordataire d'alsace moselle
elle a été prise parce que la loi de
1905 ne s'applique pas chez nous et
notamment l'article 2 qui indique qui
prévoit que l'état ne reconnaît et ne
finance aucun culte
pour autant la ville ne pouvait pas
s'exonérer d'une étude précise et
spécifique sur l'intérêt de cette
subvention au regard de l'intérêt
général et de l'ordre public
cette étude n'a pas été réalisé et je me
félicite que l'état est déferré cette
décision tribunal administratif
je vous remercie monsieur yum
merci monsieur le président je vous prie
tout d'abord d'excusés ma collègue
patricia schillinger qui est
convalescente
elle avait à coeur en tant que
parlementaire alsacienne de réitérer son
attachement au droit local et à la
pratique concordataire nous retrouvons
le débat que nous venons d'avoir cet
attachement vous l'aurez remarqué
transcende largement les différentes
sensibilités politiques qui s'expriment
dans notre assemblée la patrie la
pratique concordataire a permis en
alsace-moselle d'atteindre un équilibre
entre liberté religieuse laïcité et plus
largement valeurs de la république alors
que ce projet de loi procède sur tout le
territoire au renforcement des
obligations pesant sur les associations
cultuelles minutes était imprudent voire
dangereux de ne pas renforcer celles qui
incombent aux associations cultuelles de
droit local
nous aurions vu le risque de voir des
territoires régis par le droit local se
muer en refuge d'une forme de
séparatisme religieux attiré par un
cadre juridique devenu permissifs en
comparaison de celui appliqué au reste
du territoire
donc nous saluons la proche apaisé et
compréhensive adoptée par le
gouvernement qui n'a pas souhaité
renvoyer les associations de droit local
à l'application pure et simple de la loi
de 1905 mais a procédé par transposition
dans le droit local de certaines
dispositions de la loi de 1905 c'est une
attente forte des territoires concernés
pour s'assurer de la préservation de
leurs spécificités et si les élus
alsaciens et mosellans se réjouissent
des garanties obtenues jusqu'à présent
nous considérons qu'il était encore
possible d'intégrer au texte certaines
précautions afin de s'assurer qu'il
n'ait pour effet ni de modifier le
régime spécial des cultes need entravé
de manière exagérée le fonctionnement
des établissements publics de ces cultes
soumis déjà à des contraintes
spécifiques
enfin dans un souci d'égalité nous
proposons l'extension à ces
établissements publics de culte de la
faculté d'acquérir des immeubles à titre
gratuit qui est déjà ouverte aux
associations cultuelles
merci chers collègues à l'article 31
nous avons un amendement du gouvernement
numéro 6 189 avec 5,6 sous-amendement
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président il s'agit
d'un d'un moment qui arrive en premier
puisqu'il vise à réécrire l'article va
normalement s'il devait être adopté ce
que nous souhaitons pouvoir empêcher les
discussions d'un certain nombre
d'amendements puisque comme l'a très
bien dit le les divers sénateurs comme
l'entrée lundi par universal nateur nous
avons souhaité non pas faire des
références à la loi de 1905 en 1901 mais
réécrire en droit local la codification
du droit local des dispositions de la
république qui s'imposerait par la loi
votée par ses représentants
ce qui me permet de souligner ici je lis
notamment à tous ceux qui nous écoutent
qu' il faut savoir distinguer comme cela
était déjà répété le concordat du droit
local droit local qui est composé à la
fois de l'équivalent des dispositions
cultuelle dit 1905 sur les cultes qui
sont des cultes reconnus et les cultes
non reconnu et du droit de l'association
puisque c'est pas faire injure à
l'alsace et la moselle que de rappeler
qu'en 1900 lorsque législateur a créé
cette grande loi d'associations l'avait
ses labs n était pas le territoire de la
république française et qui avait donc
il ya un droit local associatif qui
représente grosso modo ce qui existe
dans la loi 1901 à des exceptions près
notamment le fait que c'est au tribunal
judiciaire par exemple que l'on à la
démarche de création d'associations bref
à part ces distinctions il s'agit bien
des lois qui sont miroir on pourra les
appeler comme ça mais qui s'applique de
manière différente dans un endroit qui
est différent mais dont le conseil
d'état et le conseil constitutionnel ont
reconnu à plusieurs reprises qu'il ne
faisait ni obstacle à l'unité de la
république ni obstacle au fait que la
laïcité telle que
105 imaginer ou 1901 l'imaginé
s'applique à la république et que par
ailleurs je répète que le principe de
non reconnaissance qui est aussi un
principe d'alsace-moselle puisqu'il ya
au moins quatre cultes reconnus donc par
définition n'a pas qu'un seul qui ait
reconnu que le principe de non
reconnaissance est évidemment rasic
constitutionnel mais je veux redire au
sénat que le principe de non
subventionnement n'est pas un principe
constitutionnel et relève de la loi de
la république et non des principes
fondamentalement fondamentaux pardon
reconnu valoir la république
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire que si
le conseil constitutionnel le souhaitait
faire oeuvre d'une grande jurisprudence
quelle que soit l'opinion que l'on
pourrait porter sur elle pourrait
imaginer constitutionnaliser dans le le
bloc de constitutionnalité ce principe
de non subventionnement est alors
entraînerait beaucoup de conséquences
sur les baux emphytéotiques ceux des
reçus fiscaux
bref sur un season 2 de subventionnement
non direct enfin qui quand même utilise
beaucoup l'argent public on a eu ce
débat a été garantie d'emprunt notamment
la semaine dernière ce qui par ailleurs
souligné au sénateur communiste kke
bien sûr il ya des différences mais elle
laisse aussi du fait que dans les
principes de l'alsace moselle on peut
subventionner les cultes et donc du coup
le reçu fiscal qui est une sorte de
compensation de la non subventionnement
n'est pas au rendez vous donc c'est
différenciateur existent et sont
consubstantiels indifférence des deux
législations
l'amendement du gouvernement vise à
appliquer les lois de la république en
alsace moselle en respectant le droit
local ce qui me pousse à dire que le
droit local n'est pas un droit morts
c'est un droit qui est vivant et à ce
titre il peut connaître des
modifications des suppressions des
ajouts c'est ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui nous pouvons une différence
sur le fond nous n'avons pas de
différence sur la forme c'est bien du
droit local et ce droit local dont le
garde des sceaux d'ailleurs à réactiver
la commission vous l'avez mesdames et
messieurs des mets parlementaire ne fait
pas obstacle à ce que ce que décident
les représentants du peuple et le
gouvernement s'impose en alsace-moselle
simplement traduit dans le droit local
comme lorsque nous le faisons tous
quasiment à chaque projet doit nous
prévoyons des dispositions
exceptionnelles
pour le territoire ultramarin ou pour le
territoire corse ça ne veut pas dire
qu'ils ne sont pas dans la république
bien évidemment ces dispositions sont
toujours prévues en général dans les
projets de loi pour s'adapter à ça donne
aux dispositions respectant ainsi la
parole de l'histoire et finalement du
gouvernement de la république qui a
voyant revenir les élus d'alsace moselle
à la fois pleurer conclu qu' évidemment
ne devait pas changer les avancées ou en
tout cas des dizaines d'années de
législation spécifique et qui encore une
fois n'a rien à voir avec le concordat
octroyé par effectivement le premier
consul nous sommes devant un amendement
monsieur le président qui vient résumé
l'ensemble des dispositions pour le
traduire directement en droit local joue
à donner un avis deux positions aux
diverses aux abandons notamment celui
évoqué par monsieur recherche non pas
que nous soyons des accords je crois sur
le fond mais nous ne souhaitons pas
étendre particulièrement des
dispositions qui ne serait pas appliquée
ailleurs sur le territoire national
enfin c'est une différence de fond
notamment pour les epci et donne un avis
favorable sous un moment de madame la
rapporteure dont je crois comprendre que
la maman telle que rédigée par le
gouvernement satisfait votre demande et
donc comme je sais que le gouvernement
devrait ayant déposé son un moment
embrasser l'ensemble des discussions
ensuite je souhaitais le souligne bien
alors comme l'a dit monsieur le ministre
il y a 6 sous-amendement donc on va les
présenter l'un après l'autre le 404 mal
à la présidente de l'ajs si monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues pour poursuivre l'idée émise
dans mon amant dans 403 sur l'article 12
bis pour mieux contrôler les finances
des associations cultuelles à l'instar
des fonds d'origine étrangère convient
de donner plus de moyens plus de
visibilité aux activités d'exercice
public du culte au moyen d'une
comptabilité autonome il faut
aujourd'hui que les déclarations des
associations cultuelles soient
vérifiables plus aisément sur les plans
social comptable et fiscale lorsqu'il
s'agira notamment de demande
l'exonération de droits et de taxes
permise par leurs activités
par ailleurs puisque le code de commerce
oblige ces associations cultuelles à une
certification passé
cent cinquante trois mille euros de
subventions publiques ce sous-amendement
va plus loin et propose que soient pris
en compte la totalité des ressources
annuelles pour là encore faciliter
l'application de ce contrôle des
finances merci merci le 272 monsieur
young
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement vise à étendre aux
établissements publics du culte le droit
de posséder d'administrer des immeubles
à titre gratuit
je l'avais évoqué tout à l'heure par
souci d'égalité avec les associations
cultuelles du droit général qui à
l'article 28 de la présente loi se sont
vus ouvrir la possibilité de posséder
d'administrer des immeubles à titre
gratuit
cet amendement propose d'étendre donc
aux établissements publics du culte
cette même faculté l'élargissement
proposé semble tout à fait cohérent par
rapport au traitement qui est fait des
associations à but culturel dans le
droit général
cet amendement leur confère tout
simplement le même droit et je crois que
d'autres amendements identiques ont été
déposées merci effectivement le
reichardt 460 est strictement identique
oui monsieur le président il a été
parfaitement défendu je rajouterais
simplement que dans la mesure où je me
souviens avoir entendu monsieur le
ministre dira que ne pas accepter que
ces associations puissent percevoir les
fruits de d'immeubles consisterait à
mener ces associations à les vendre
pour se faire de l'argent toute façon
puisqu'il faut bien qu'elle fonctionne
je voudrais juste rappeler qu'ici aussi
une association objets cultuels devra
locale donc un établissement public du
recul pourrait procéder exactement de la
même façon
donc ce que nous souhaitons là c'est
simplement une égalité de traitement et
je me félicite à cet égard que la
commission des lois est bien voulu
donner un avis favorable à cet égard je
vous remercie mes chers collègues de
bien vouloir voter c'est sous un nom non
merci
ensuite monsieur richard des nouveaux
visiblement le 241 président hosni
j'ai bien compris que cet amendement
s'il était adopté ferait tomber tous les
amendements suivant c'est la raison pour
laquelle il était important de reprendre
l'un ou l'autre de ces amendements sous
amendements et c'est l'objet de celui ci
comme lui précédent en fait la ligne à
42 de cet article 31 du présent projet
de loi crée un nouvel article
nos code pénal local d'alsace moselle
qui interdit de tenir des réunions
politiques dans un local servant
habituellement à l'exercice du culte ou
dans les dépendances qui en constitue un
accessoire le présent amendement entend
donc bien maintenir l'objectif principal
du dispositif en interdisant toute
réunion politique dans un local servant
habituellement à l'exercice d'un culte
mais d'en retirer les dépendances qui
ont constitué un accessoire
indissociables en effet une interdiction
étendue à ses dépendances vient de
déposer une difficultés logistiques
majeurs dont de nombreux territoires
d'alsace moselle où ces salles font
régulièrement l'objet de location pour
l'organisation de réunions politiques
sans que cela ne donne lieu à des
incidents menaçant le respect des
principes de la review à titre personnel
j'ai dû en faire une centaine dans des
dépendances de lieux de culte depuis le
début de ma carrière politique du fait
de la non application de la loi de 1905
en alsace-moselle cela fait 116 ans mes
chers collègues que des réunions se
tiennent dans de telles salles
paroissiales
ce qui n'est naturellement pas le cas
dans le reste de la france puisque loi
de 1905
c'est par les
église de l'état vous n'avez pas cette
habitude d'alors chez nous cette
pratique est devenue une vraie tradition
sur laquelle à mon avis il est vraiment
souhaitable de ne pas revenir je vous
remercie amendements identiques 274
monsieur young merci merci monsieur le
président oui c'est un amendement
identique ce je ne vais donc pas
reprendre ce que vient de dire
excellemment notre collègue richard
je comprends et je soutiens tout à fait
ses prises de position pour ceux d'entre
vous qui connaissent la vie au royaume
uni c'est la même chose au royaume uni
on peut utiliser les différents tente
pour tout type de réunions et c'est bien
c'est bien battre de ne pas s'en de s'en
priver
eh bien le 690 madame le reporter il
s'agissait d'interdire aux personnes
condamnées pour terrorisme de pouvoir
être président est une association qui
inclut des mineurs et donc c'était un
amendement pour lequel la commission
était favorable et que je représente ici
sous forme de sous-amendements bon alors
tant que vous y êtes madame la reporter
si vous vouliez nous donner la vie sur
l'amendement alors sur le mouvement du
gouvernement c'est un avis
favorable puisque effectivement comme
vous le disiez monsieur le ministre vous
repreniez un certain nombre d'éléments y
compris que nous avions voté dans la
commission donc nous sommes favorables à
cette coordination au niveau de
l'article 31
donnez-nous l'avis de la commission sur
les sous-amendement qu'ils ne sont pas
seuls là que la commission l'avis de la
commission également sur les
sous-amendement alors l'amendement de
madame delattre qui vise à remplacer
certification du commissaire aux comptes
par une attestation nous en avons déjà
largement débattue en dehors de l'alsace
moselle et donc nous y sommes tout aussi
défavorable lorsque c'est en alsace
moselle
l'amendement de madame schilling heures
concernant la gestion des immeubles
acquis à titre gratuit donc c'est le 272
et l' amendement identique 460
effectivement je pense que et nous
allons en reparler
ça peut être bien de traiter de la même
façon les associations en alsace-moselle
que en vieille france et donc nous y
sommes favorables
nous passons par contre aux 241 qui vise
à exclure le fait que alors dans la loi
1905 n'interdisait pas de faire des
réunions dans les lieux attenants au
lieu de culte mais ce projet de loi
aujourd'hui sur la partie vieille france
l'interdît interdit d'avoir des réunions
politiques dans les lieux attenants au
lieu de culte est effectivement l'idée
est de vraiment séparer le spirituel du
temporel le politique de la religion et
donc les lieux attenants au lieu de
culte doivent avoir une vocation de
poursuite du culte et non pas politique
et c'est pourquoi sur le projet de loi c
supprimés sur l'ensemble de du
territoire sauf potentiellement en
alsace-moselle si on n'applique pas ce
droit à l'alsace moselle est
que demande cet amendement monsieur
reichardt étant bien plus éloquent que
moi il a emporté la vie de la commission
donc l'avis est favorable à exclure les
dépendances de la loi et donc à faire
qu'on puisse tenir des réunions
politiques dans les dépendances
sachez que les rapporteurs il était donc
je vous précise bien l'amendement 241 et
l'identique 274 les rapporteurs y était
opposée nous pensons et en plus les
débats actuels montrent bien que me
semble-t-il
a strasbourg une mosquée se construit
elle n'est pas seule il y a tout un
ensemble culturel autour
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il faille
transformer cet ensemble culturel en un
endroit où des meetings politiques
puissent se tenir
mais si jamais cet amendement 241 où 274
été votée c'est bien évidemment ce qui
pourrait se faire et ça ne pourrait se
faire qu'en alsace moselle parce que
pour le reste de la france dans ce
projet de loi nous avons supprimé cette
possibilité et enfin ben oui enfin
c'était notre amendement évidemment nous
y sommes favorables pour le 690 me alors
à 20h donc sur le gouvernement j'ai bien
compris que c'était un avis favorable
sur le sous-amendement de la commission
apparemment défavorable sur les cinq
autres non je vous demande pas de la
commission je parle du gouvernement
madame le reporter sauf si vous voulez
être ministre tout de suite mais laissez
donc le mini s'exprimer je suis tout à
fait monsieur le président juste suivre
pour madame delattre que c'est un sou un
moment miroir d'un amendement qui avait
déposé dans le corps de notre séance qui
a été refusé et donc pas paris-sg des
formes ce serait étonnant qu'on la dope
pour l'alsace moselle est pas pour
l'assemblée pour le reste part du
territoire national donc ça n'avait un
avis défavorable de miroir si j'ose dire
voilà est défavorable au reste je le
suis déjà expliqué ce présent sauf
savons maintenant à porte très bien
on va essayer dans la joie et la bonne
humeur c'est quand je vous dis qu'on va
lever à 20 heures je vous le garantis
maintenant monsieur ouzoulias ce plus
qu'on lève à 20 heures pour les votre
temps merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
trois petits points
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit très
justement qu'il n'était pas question
d'offrir à ces nouvelles associations
inscrites les mêmes avantages fiscaux
que les associations de 1905
parce qu'elles touchent des subventions
or ce qu'on sait que ce qui vous est
réclamée là c'est une transposition des
libéralités fiscal des associations loi
de 1905 sur ces associations cultuelles
donc elle aurait à la fois les libertés
les libéralités fiscale du régime 1905
plus le subventionnement ce qui crée une
nouvelle fois un déséquilibre moi je
veux revenir sur la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 5 août 2011 dit
somodia en effet le conseil
constitutionnel considère que le droit
local n'est pas mort il doit être vivant
mais à deux conditions qu'il aille vers
l'abrogation ou l'harmonisation avec le
droit commun c'est-à-dire avec les
listes nation française je ne suis pas
sûr du tout du tout que c'est ce que
vous proposez par par ce texte
ce que je crains c'est que cet article
soit censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel et l'alsace moselle se
retrouve avec un régime qui permettra en
effet l'implantation sur son territoire
d'associations qui veulent échapper aux
nouvelles dispositions de la loi de 1905
enfin chers collègues vous nous dites
que le concordat s'éteint un modèle et
que
la france sur tout son territoire
devrait s'en inspirer
permettez moi de vous dire que c'est
quand même un paradoxe
je vais vous rappeler la constitution de
1958 et vous voyez on est arrivé au
moment du débat où c'est un sénateur
communiste comme j défendre la
constitution de 1958
la cour l'a défini la constitution de
1958 elle dit la france est une
république indivisible laïque et
démocratique
donc si vous voulez transposer le droit
local d'alsace-moselle à la france il
faut changer la constitution de 1958 et
là on est prêt à vous aider
on est prêt à vous aider parce que nous
il a toujours combattu cet homme
cette constitution merci monsieur le
président bien je vous remercie
infiniment
allez monsieur richard towa l'année où
monsieur le président je voulais pas
intervenir mais je peux pas laisser dire
je peux pas laisser dire ce que vient de
dire monsieur ozu liasses je suis en
train nous sommes en train de déposer un
amendement pour faire en sorte que les
associations objets cultuels puissent
bénéficier simplement des mêmes droits
que les associations cultuelles tels que
à l'heure actuelle elles sont
introduites bien et puis vous êtes en
train de dire que non parce
qu'effectivement ils touchent de
l'argent d'orzy les touches quoi comme
argent rien à voir les ministres
ridicules ils sont payés les
associations ne touche rien de plus les
ministres des cultes qui sont payés vous
savez pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement à l'époque on a
simplement pris les biens la révolution
prix les biens du clergé qui permettait
justement du pays à ses milices du recul
il n'avait plus les moyens
donc d'où le concorde a donc des
ministres des cultes qui sont payés ça
rien à voir avec les associations objets
cultuels
donc s'il vous plaît je suis en train de
demander à ce que simplement on fasse
une parité une équité de fonctionnement
et vous attendrez vous vous touchez déjà
ça mais vous allez vous sortez de la
barrique non je peux pas laisser dire ça
allait
c'est dit c'est dit
eh bien on va commencer par le vote des
sous-amendements puis on finira par le
vote de l'amendement
si dieu le veut le 404 rectifier le 404
rectifié de la présidente de lattre avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour et
pour même de la toile à la présidente
votre amendement vous le voté oui alors
levé la main merci
l'ange dit ça use les quais contre il
n'est pas adopté le 272 avec un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement
c'est le même je le précise tout de
suite que le 460 donc vote identique qui
est pour 2,2 contre
ils sont adoptés le 241 qui est
identique au 274 avis favorable de la
commission des favorites du gouvernement
qu'est pour eux mêmes vote qui est
contre ils sont adoptés et enfin la
moment là que le sous-amendement la
commission le 690 avec un avis favorable
du gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
[Musique]
il est adopté et sur le coup je mets au
voir l'amendement 689 du gouvernement
sous amendé par les amendements communs
de voter qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté sa tête on
découvre donc tous les amendements tombe
et l'article 31 est ainsi rédigé après
l'article 31 un amendement 461 monsieur
richard tu as quand même
le 461 hausse il est retiré très bien
qu'est ce que c'est bon on revient aux
articles non réservez donc après
l'article 55
j'ai un amendement un sous-amendement un
amendement du gouvernement le 691
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président il s'agit
d'un moment important arrivé tardivement
j'en conviens bien volontiers en séance
j'ai pris soin de prendre attache avec
monsieur le président de la commission
même si évidemment déposé en début
d'après midi que dit cet amendement qui
vient compléter utilement le travail que
nous avons fait depuis plusieurs mois
autour de ce texte et qui a été
particulièrement sollicité par de
nombreux élus je veux dire à quel point
c c est lui qui ont sollicité le
ministère de l'intérieur sont de tous
bords politiques différents
je pense à monsieur le maire
d'albertville je pense a mentionné de
clichy également à qui je me suis
entretenu puisque aujourd'hui un travail
important a été fait vous l'avez vue sur
la situation des écoles hors contrat
particulièrement la ppl gatel non
monsieur l'éducation nationale j'ai
l'occasion de souligner l'importance ici
et des dispositions présentées à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat sur
l'ouverture de ces écoles mais nous
constatons que l'une des conséquences de
nos dispositions
c'est que malheureusement de façon ex
ante et ne pouvons nous opposer en droit
actuel à l'ouverture d'une école et
d'une école on comptera bien évidemment
alors que elle est manifestement la
caractéristique d'une ingérence
étrangère ou d'une atteinte à la
souveraineté de notre pays à ses
principes fondamentaux qui consisterait
effectivement à tirer la conclusion
notamment du fait qu'une association
dénommée ligue russe ne pourrait pas
ouvrir des écoles hors contrat alors
même qu'ils n'ont pas si la charte des
valeurs de vie stable et que nous nous
opposons on l'a vu dans le cas de la
mosquée de strasbourg à la construction
de notre disposition ils sont désormais
dans ce projet de loi et que national
bien voulu adopter
il s'agit de tirer toute conclusion ans
j'entends la ligne qui concerne mais je
sais que le sénat puisse en prendre
connaissance
sixième alinéa de l'article l 441 du
code de l'éducation dans l'associé bien
sûr le musée national a vécu de nombreux
échanges et dont la rédaction était
corrigée avec son cabinet le
représentant de l'état en l'occurrence
se presser il s'agit bien de la
souveraineté de notre pays
ces relations internationales et de ce
qui relève effectivement d'une action
sur ses intérêts fondamentaux
le représentant de l'état dans le
département peut également formé
opposition peut également tomber donc
évidemment s'est soumis à une
appréciation et et dont on peut imaginer
que il ya un recours pour cette décision
du représentant étape à une telle
ouverture pour des motifs tirés
des relations entre la chaîne la france
ou la défense de sa souveraineté ce qui
veux très clairement dire que l'avons vu
suite à la tribune du maire
d'intervilles alors même que chacun
souhaite s'opposer à l'ouverture de ces
écoles hors contrat aspirés directement
par des états ou par des ingérences
étrangères et c'est ben clairement nous
donnons la possibilité aux services de
l'état déplore nous opposer à de telles
ouvertures d'écoles
je crois que le monsieur le président
monsieur le président la commission des
lois un sous-amendement et je donne un
avis par avance c'est à dire favorables
concorde qui anime la montée du
gouvernement monsieur le président la
commission des lois
monsieur le président mais ce ministre
chers collègues
effectivement le moment est arrivé dans
le courant de l'après-midi mais nous
avons pu échanger et que ministre sur
son objet sur les conditions dans
lesquelles il est
dalet être déposée naturellement il
répond à une préoccupation qui est
apparu très rapidement et très récemment
en particulier albertville et je regarde
notre collègue l'alberta qui est
sénatrice et notament ancien maire
d'interviews qui connaît parfaitement la
situation et donc il fait donner un avis
un accord sur le dépôt si tenté que j'ai
un accord a donné sauf qu'il vient d'un
avis de la commission
dans quelques instants cette commission
n'ayant pas été tant de thuraya par
ailleurs mais dans la rédaction de
l'amendement qui me convient
s'il souhaitait quand même apporté une
modification ne nous a demandé pour
remplacer
la phrase ou de l'aide de la défense de
sa souveraineté par une formule de son
inutile d'y adapter ses intérêts de ses
intérêts fondamentaux
pourquoi parce que ces formules est
d'abord connu dans notre droit
utilisez régulièrement sur lequel on
sait quel contenu
et là il me paraissait plus adaptés ne
sont pas utilisés aussi dans code pénal
donc à la faveur de sous-amendements
naturellement à titre personnel je
soutiendrai d'un mouvement de bras non
merci alors amis de la commission alors
j'ai présidente comme l'a appelé
monsieur le président de la commission
évidemment nous avons eu cet après midi
cet amendement donc la commission s'est
pas réuni voilà à titre personnel mais
je pense que la commission
il me semblerait a mis un avis favorable
à cet amendement
parce que les événements de ce week-end
et des événements madame berthe
effectivement est bien placé pour le
savoir nous ont tous interpellés et à
interpeller évidemment le préfet de
cette région je l' ai juste dire
monsieur ministre ce qui prouve ce que
nous avons vécu ensemble et ce pour quoi
nous allons probablement prenez une
position là dans les secondes qui
suivent
ça prouve que dans le texte ya encore
des trous dans la raquette et que les
trous dans la raquette il va falloir que
nous continuons à aller regarder
ensemble et je pense que les apports du
sénat dans ce texte vous permettront
aussi prendre de bonnes décisions sur
des choses que nous aurons réglé tous
ensemble voilà donc c'est plutôt un avis
favorable je pense
non et au soudan
bien évidemment de notre cher président
si alors prise de parole monsieur le
comte
merci monsieur le président monsieur bis
mais chaque collègue à titre personnel
je suis très mal à l'aise avec cet
amendement parce que je comprends bien
ce qui vous anime et c'est totalement
légitime
toutefois il n'y a pas que des états il
peut y avoir énormément de deux raisons
qui peuvent conduire à ce que une école
qu'on ne souhaite pas l'ouverture d'une
école et qu'elle ne soit pas conforme à
l'intérêt général et et ce devant cela
devrait passer par une autorisation
préalable
nous avons eu tout ce débat auprès et
finalement c'est le prix que nous payons
de ne pas avoir donné d'autorisation
préalable que d'avoir à voter cet
amendement et je sais aussi comme
sénateur des français à l'étranger
comment parfois sont perçus un certain
nombre de nos écoles dans un certain
nombre de pays en particulier lorsque
nous avons des discussions aux diplômés
des relations diplomatiques un peu tendu
et je n'aimerais pas que nous nous
appliquions le risque que ceux ci
tournée si nous avions mis en place un
régime d'autorisation préalable nous
nous serions assurés au préalable que le
projet d'ouverture d'une école serait
conforme aux principes de la république
et à l'intérêt général
nous ne l'avons pas fait nous payons ce
prix avec cet amendement et nous
risquons nous risquons de la réciprocité
de trouver dans un seconde de situations
où un certain nombre d'écoles françaises
à l'étranger qui sont parfois accusé
dans la presse de ces pays
de ce que nous avons pu lire ces
derniers jours d'être fermé et je le
souhaite pas il me semble que nous
devons avoir un principe général
le principe général c'est l'autorisation
préalable nous ne l'avons pas voter
voilà c'est l'incohérence de notre texte
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est un moment c'est le deus ex machina
c'est la façon de réintroduire comme l'a
dit très justement notre collègue
lecomte l'autorisation préfectorale dans
un dispositif que vous avez souhaitait
absolument déclaratif et on voit bien
dans quel apories vous êtes parce que en
effet quand on est dans un système
déclaratif
on ne peut pas faire valoir les intérêts
de l'état par son représentant
préalablement au dépôt donc derrière
vous êtes obligés de découper par
rapport à une situation locale qui vous
échappe complètement
je suis très triste de la rédaction de
cet amendement qui ne renvoie que ils
sont je suis tout à fait d'accord pour
les respecter un mais il s'agit d'écoles
et on nous parle d un terreau les
intérêts fondamentaux de la france
moi j'ai rien j'aurais aimé que dans un
système d'autorisation vous vous parlez
acier des intérêts fondamentaux de
l'enfant et des droits de l'enfant et
des droits de l'enfant ils sont absents
si vous aviez accepté un système
d'autorisation
ce qui aurait été mis en avant 6,6 en
avant ici c'est le dossier pédagogique
déposée par l'association et en fonction
de ce dossier pédagogique nous aurions
pu le préfet l'administration de
l'éducation nationale aurait pu vérifier
que le dossier pédagogique était
conforme au respect des droits
essentiels à l'instruction et à
l'émancipation de l'enfant là je trouve
regrettable que sur une question d'école
vous un trait dizier des choses qui ne
rend les vaps non pas de la pédagogie
mais de quelque chose qui se gère au
niveau diplomatique et gérer l'ouverture
des écoles dans les territoires en
fonction des relations diplomatiques ça
me semble être une très mauvaise chose
pour pour l'école voilà monsieur le
président merci j'ai encore plusieurs
demandes de parole donc voilà c'est
calme monsieur le président la faune
président bon c'est évidemment toujours
un peu gênant après quasiment deux
semaines de débats de découvrir un
amendement au dernier moment et après
plusieurs semaines de de travail on a
toujours la crainte dans ces cas-là de
légiférer un peu dans l'urgence avec
plus de questions laissées en suspens ce
que de que de réponses vraiment apporté
il est évident quand on regarde quand on
lit le d'amendements du gouvernement on
est frappé dans un premier temps par
l'imprécision où le flou générés par
certains termes
je ne sais pas précisément ce que veut
dire en droit les motifs liés à des
relations internationales par exemple et
donc je ne peux qu'avoir un regard
intéressé bienveillant par rapport à la
hausse ou amendement de la commission
des lois qui précise de manière quand
même beaucoup plus rigoureuses ce qui
est recherché
moi j'ai une interrogation sur le fait
qu' on ne fait pas référence en fait à
la question du financement à travers cet
amendement directement j'aurais préféré
que
la question soit abordée à travers la
directement la question du financement
parce que j'ai un peu peur des
interprétations jurisprudentielles qui
peuvent être faits de l'écriture de cet
amendement vous savez qu'on est dans le
groupe union centriste évidemment très
attaché à la loi gatel et que cet
amendement vient on va dire compléter la
loi gatel comme peut-être il ya des
compléments apportés mais en tout cas ça
suppose de notre part une vigilance on a
bien compris les annales les l'intérêt
de ceux de cet amendement et la
nécessité sans doute de compléter le
dispositif
c'est pour cela que nous nous joindrons
à la fois aux suffisamment non comme je
les dis mais aussi à l'amendement du
gouvernement mais en ayant quelques
questions à la fois sur la rédaction et
quelques regrets sur le fait qu'ils
n'apparaissent que maintenant merci
madame berthet oui monsieur le président
je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur ministre
d'avoir pris en compte effectivement la
demande de très nombreux élus
d'albertville de la savoie mais de façon
bien plus large également ce problème
effectivement est apparue albertville
mais ç'aurait pu être tout à fait
ailleurs et on ne peut pas laisser les
mères démunies face à de telles
situations
bien sûr le coeur du problème c'est le
respect des principes des valeurs de
notre république est comment peut-on en
être certain être certain que ces
valeurs seront respectées face à une
association qui n'a pas souhaité signer
la charte de ses valeurs donc c'est je
pense cet amendement permettra de
résoudre ces problèmes auxquels le maire
d'albertville et certainement bien
d'autres auraient pu être confrontés
jeunesse merci monsieur brisson
président je fais mienne et les
remarques de forme et de fond du
président la forum le présent notre
commission mais
je voudrais sur le fond apporter mon
soutien à cet amendement et aux
amendements de la commission mardi
dernier j'ai plutôt défendu les
établissements hors contrat et je me
suis j'ai défendu le régime de
déclaration qui essuient de l'orga tél
nous sommes confrontés à nos réalités
que la perdre à belleville a mise en
valeur s'agit de lutter contre
séparatisme or tout cet après midi j'ai
entendu parler du concordat d'alsace
lorraine
j'ai entendu parler des situations
particulières de guyane de mayotte ou de
nos territoires d'outre-mer et pendant
tout l'après midi je me suis demandé où
est la lutte contre le séparatisme est
incontestablement est contestable le
mans sur l'amendement du gouvernement on
retrouve le un vrai sujet il ne s'agit
pas de fermer tous les établissements
il s'agit d'avoir un outil face à des
ingérences étrangères qui vise alors le
séparatisme par rapport à la république
donc je maintiens ma position sur le
yoga tel le régime de dca saut parce
qu'il ne faut pas que la machine tombe
sur ceux qui n'ont rien fait et c'est
bien souvent le danger de ce texte c'est
que fait lendemain ils sont utilisés par
l'administration contre des acteurs qui
n'ont rien à voir avec le séparatisme
mais lorsque l'on à un élément du texte
qui confondent la lutte contre ces
pratiques
j'encourage mes amis à le voter merci
monsieur le premier questeur philippe
bas
merci monsieur le président moi je suis
tout à fait favorable cet amendement tel
que notre président de la commission des
lois la sous-amendé je voudrais tenter
de rassurer le président de notre
commission d'éducation et de la culture
n'oublions pas que ces décisions qui ne
pourront avoir qu'un caractère tout à
fait exceptionnelles seront prises sous
le contrôle d'un juge et qu' il faudra à
ce moment là que le préfet justifie la
réalité de la menace qu'il veut prévenir
en s'opposant à la création d'une telle
école mais mes chers collègues nous
avons refusé de soumettre à autorisation
l'école à la maison
nous avons considéré que c'était une
mesure disproportionnée par rapport à
l'objectif poursuivi
je voyais de la part du gouvernement
dans cet amendement
une forme de reconnaissance de la proche
que nous avons eues avec la recherche
d'une autre réponse que celle qu'il
avait initialement proposé cet autre
réponse c'est quand une école est créée
et qu'elle est en réalité le fer de
lance d'islamistes radicaux par exemple
qui sont entièrement aux mains d'un pays
étranger
mettons du moyen-orient à ce moment là
on pourra les interdire
et ça réduit une partie de la
préoccupation que le gouvernement avait
eu lorsqu'il avait dit je ne veux plus
d'école à la maison parce que une partie
des enfants qui sont soit disant à la
maison pour recevoir une éducation sont
en réalité dans des écoles coraniques et
bien voilà ce genre d'école quand elles
sont financées et contrôlés par des pays
étrangers on pourra les interdire je
crois que c'est une manière de prendre
acte de notre vote et donc je veux
rendre au gouvernement
le les bonnes manières qu'il a à l'égard
du sénat représentant cet amendement
monsieur le testeur sueur après je lève
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je ne partage pas totalement le
point de vue de philippe bas qui parle
d'une bonne manière
pensez vous que l'arrivée inopinée
d'amendements qui n'ont été discutée
évidemment ni en commission ni nulle
part ailleurs
soit une bonne manière à l'égard du cdh
à monsieur le président et d'un sujet de
discussion je dirais que je comprends
comme je comprenais la semaine dernière
ce qui motive notre ministre ce qui
s'est passé à strasbourg la semaine
dernière ce qui est susceptible de se
passer dans une autre ville de france
cette semaine et je comprends tout à
fait l'inquiétude est en même temps les
problèmes que cela peut poser la seule
question que nous posons c'est de savoir
si c'est par les mesures indiquées dans
cet amendement que nous allons parvenir
à trouver une solution
comme l'a excellemment dit jean yves le
conte faisons très attention quand on
met dans le l'objet l'idéologie il va y
avoir des pays qui vont nous renvoyer
l'ascenseur en nous disant mais il y ait
en france vous avez une idéologie laïque
il hors de question que cette idéologie
se répandent chez nous si on se met en
les sciences mais raisonner ainsi
il faut prendre en compte l'ensemble du
sujet et puis il y à la question
préalable en quelque sorte
et d'ailleurs vous savez plus nous
discutons sur ce texte
puis nous plus nous voyons que la
question préalable le posée par patrick
kader était excellente
parce qu'on s'éloigne toujours plus
de la lutte contre le djihadisme nocifs
violents etc pour toute une série de
mesures qui ont une autre nature
alors nous pensons que les maires ont
des droits des devoirs dans la
république que le préfet exerce son
contrôle de légalité et que tout cela
est en effet cher philippe bas sous le
contrôle du juge
et c'est pourquoi nous ne souscrivons
pas à cet amendement hâtif qui est sans
doute une solution trop rapide à une
question qu'il faut regarder au fond il
égard au pouvoir des maires tout
simplement
et ils lui en veulent et à aller au rôle
du juge
merci madame de la gontrie avant madame
billon et je précise tout de suite que
visiblement il ya une demande de scrutin
public où on en est merci au président
cet amendement évidemment est important
mais je dirai au président bas que je l'
ai connues plus exigeants juriste
puisque nous voyons bien qu'il ya deux
motifs qui sont évoquées des motifs
tirés des relations internationales de
la france ou de la défense de sa
souveraineté
alors le sous-amendement du président la
commission des lois évidemment est
bienvenu car les intérêts fondamentaux
de la france
on sait juridiquement de quoi on parle
en revanche les motifs tirés des
relations internationales de la france
je ne sais pas de quoi on parle et
lorsque nous sommes en train de faire la
loi
nous devons donner des critères précis
sachant que le président bat d'ailleurs
fait appel à la notion de menace
il n'est nulle part parlé de menaces il
est parlé de motifs tirés des relations
internationales de la france
alors la question est celle là si demain
les relations internationales évolué
bien sûr elle évolue que se passe-t-il
l'école est fermée comment est ce que le
préfet va-t-il fonctionner à ce moment
là on ne peut pas être dans l'aléatoire
dents
le discrétionnaire jean yves lecompte a
parfaitement eu raison de dire que nous
avons souhaité l'autorisation préalable
vous ne l'avez pas venu mais au moins
nous sommes cohérents mais je vous le
dis si vous votez cette disposition
cela veut dire que demain en fonction de
l'actualité telle ou telle école pourra
être fragilisées ou pas alors j'entends
que le ministre de l'intérieur à un
sujet enfin nous avons tous un sujet
mais l'épisode d'albertville qui a été
évoqué récemment ou mais ce qui vous est
proposée aujourd'hui n'est pas la façon
de répondre parce qu'encore une fois
vous allez mettre toutes les écoles sous
le régime aléatoire de l'évolution des
relations diplomatiques de la france
et ça n'est pas suffisamment précis pour
être recevable alors madame billon merci
monsieur le président alors je vais pour
ma part voté cet amendement
ainsi amendé par la commission des lois
parce que ça répond à des situations
nouvelles à des pratiques en
augmentation et donc ses sources
d'inquiétude bien entendu on l'a entendu
avec notre collègue martin berthet tout
à l'heure par contre je souhaite quand
même exprimé comme vient de faire notre
collègue marie pierre de la gontrie
quelques inquiétudes
le préfet aura-t-il les éléments
nécessaires pour pouvoir se prononcer
dans les délais impartis
quels seront ces éléments qui vont
pouvoir le mettre en alerte et je
rejoins tout à fait ma collègue marie
pierre de la gontrie parce que les
services de l'état vont ils dressaient
des listes de pays en fonction de
l'actualité ces listes donc seront elles
mises à jour dans quelles mesures seront
elles mises à jour comment cela va-t-il
s'organiser donc ce sont de vraies
inquiétudes et donc monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous préciser la manière dont
tout ceci va être mis en oeuvre merci il
va le pouvoir d'autant plus qu'il veut
prendre la parole mais seulement après
monsieur bonnecarrère là le sous
amendement présenté par
la commission des lois avec la référence
à ses intérêts fondamentaux fait
manifestement consensus je n'ai pas le
sentiment que ce soit le cas des de la
terminologie utilisée par le
gouvernement même si nous avons bien
compris l'objectif
et c'est vrai qu'intellectuellement le
fait devait faire dépend d'une ouverture
des relations internationales de la
france est un exotique et s étonnant je
ne vois pas d'ailleurs très bien comment
on pourra faire les juridictions
administratives saisi des recours sur
ces oppositions pour apprécier elle
s'est apprécié l'intérêt général lc je
crois apprécié des intérêts fondamentaux
je n'ai pas connaissance que nos
juridictions administratives soient
outillés pour déterminer l'état des
relations internationales de la france
j'aurais donc tendance à suivre
complètement s'il le veut bien
le président de la commission des lois
et a sous-amendé sens propre
sous-amendement en écrivant simplement
que le représentant de l'état dans le
département peut également formé
opposition à une telle ouverture pour
des motifs tirés de ses intérêts
fondamentaux c'est à dire que je propose
non seulement supprimé les ans soit
entre mais également la référence aux
relations internationales de la france
ces sous-amendements étant présenté un
accord avec mes collègues du groupe
centriste avec lequel nous avons échangé
en quelques secondes merci r mais une
fois les explications de vote commençait
on ne peut plus sous-amendé par
conséquent je suis désolé mais votre
sous-amendement n'est pas recevable
c'est dommage mais c'est le règlement
monsieur le ministre je vous en prie
avant que la parole se donne au ministre
je précise qui aura deux scrutins
publics 1 sur le sous-amendement et un
sur l'amendement si chacun pouvait s'y
préparer
eh oui monsieur le ministre bien merci
monsieur le président peut-être d'abord
sur ce que nous essayons de combattre
prenons l'exemple ce n'est pas sans
doute le seul mais c'est celui le plus
marquant est sans doute le plus
inquiétant celui du binigou russe
aujourd'hui il ya plus qu on m'a demandé
des précisions ont d'établissements
scolaires qui sont affiliés à la cmc
c'est-à-dire au milieu russe implanté
sur le territoire des maternelles et des
élémentaires à blois à strasbourg à
mulhouse à vénissieux est villefranche
sur saône
à annecy à savigny-le-temple à
corbeil-essonnes à bourgoin jallieu et
abaisse sa houppe des milliers d'enfants
je n'ai pas le détail mais je suis à
votre disposition si je prends l'exemple
du groupe scolaire privé bellevue ses
390 élèves par exemple ne s'agit pas de
petites écoles de petite classe ouverte
ici ou là d'après ministère de
l'intérieur il y a dix nouveaux
établissements scolaires hors contrats
prévus dans l'année qui vient
à oyonnax a annoné à lormont avaientt
sur sec
ah bon on apprend la prononciation si ce
n'est pas de bon ta bonne part dont le
péage de roussillon à bourgoin jallieu à
villeurbanne albertville almas à belfort
et à clichy j'ai été saisi par de
nombreux maires de toutes tendances
confondues je suis expliquée notamment
bien sûr chacun a vu le maire
d'albertville mais c'est aussi le maire
de clichy qui m'a sollicité et dans les
urgences que vous évoquez mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je peux
comprendre cette frustration il aurait
été moi-même parlementaire je vous ferai
remarquer que la décision traduit
traduit très bien illustratif
froberville c'est le 9 avril c'est à
dire que à bon ton le ministère de
l'intérieur pensait qu'à partir du
moment où à la fois le maire l'éducation
nationale le préfet était d'accord pour
s'opposer à part une conjonction de
choses que l'on connaît tout sur bani
le projet pédagogique soit tout ce que
vous avez évoqué un bouton nous pensions
que le juge administratif donnerait
raison à monsieur le maire d'albertville
et le juge administratif a donné tort à
monsieur demers d'intervilles et le
maire de clichy connaît la même
malheureuse solution de ce point de vue
il ya deux solutions pour le
gouvernement soit il profiter des
quelques heures de la loi séparatisme
que nous discutons ici pour faisait un
amendement qui est manifestement et
c'était par beaucoup ici soit il
attendait dans trois ou quatre ans qu'un
nouveau texte législatives arrivent et
subissez les étonnements légitimes des
locaux mais aussi bien avouer la
population qui ne comprend pas comment
une association peut être non
signataires d'une charte
alors que l'on lui proposait l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et la
connaissance des valeurs de la
république pouvoir s'opposer à la
construction d'un lieu de culte confère
mairie de strasbourg mais a accepté d
une action d'école par dizaines avec des
milliers d'enfants concernés parce que
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
projets que nous évoquons les projets
futurs
ce sont pas des petits projets sur la
berville le ceja cmg même la sénatrice
l'a évoqué dès ce matin ce n'est pas
faire injure au secret des
correspondances de dire qu'elle m'a
sollicité pour qu'on puisse y réagir et
elle-même connaissant bien le dossier
depuis plusieurs années a évoqué ce
matin le fait qu'il fallait réagir à
cette situation mais league russe a fait
l'acquisition en 2016 d'intérêt au
quotidien et musk existantes aux un
quartier politique de la ville pour y
implanter l'école privée le projet le
projet était présenté en 2018 qui
prévoit six classes de maternelle dix
classes de primaire pour 250 élèves
son coût est estimé à 4 millions d'euros
est effectivement le financement c'est
les dons des familles les entrepreneurs
soit gardien au président de la
commission éducation qu'à ma
connaissance vous avez adopté une
modification du indus 441 1 du code de
l'éducation qui prévoit justement que
les financements sont un motif d'ordre
public d'opposition donc quand vous
regrettez monsieur le président qui fait
que ce n'avait pas été jadis prévu ça
l'a été pendant le débat parlementaire
justement son proposition me semble-t-il
gouvernementale con
jean michel blanquer était au banc mais
en tout cas cette finalité est tout
aussi prévu et malgré que le fait que le
maire s'oppose
on l'a dit à l'urbanisme et demain à
l'ouverture de l'école de très bien et
stratifié a donné tort avec des
présidents d'association qui vont dans
le bureau du maire d'albertville et qui
lisent au préfet grosso modo on s'en
fiche on le fera quand même c'est quand
même une solution pour ça c'est la
république elle veut s'opposer à ceux
qui veulent la combattre ou non dans le
cas de mulhouse dont plusieurs élus
m'ont largement interpellé ces derniers
temps à la fois sur le lieu de culte
mais aussi sur l'école depuis 2000 13
millions russes a acheté un terrain
parce que on peut effectivement dire que
le gouvernement s'y prend tardivement
fin et des dossiers qui datent de
quasiment dix ans ça achète un terrain
de 2 5 ha dans la zone de la mer rouge à
mulhouse avec pour projet d'y construire
d'y construire une salle de prière de
1500 personnes et en 2016 demande par
une consoeur point écoles
confessionnelles déposé là encore pour
des dizaines d'élèves alors que je crois
savoir qu à la fois l'autorité
préfectorale les services l'éducation
nationale et la mairie s'y opposent à
clichy sous bois aux marques et que je
suis éclectique dans les mers qui ont
des difficultés ici ou là donc je
constate d'ailleurs que tous ont un lien
avec le quartier en politique de la
ville ce qui devrait aussi nous
interpeller dans notre combat me
semble-t-il pour pour la république et
pour justement la mixité sociale
il ya eu en 2014 une proposition de 400
élèves répartis en dix neuf classes à
clichy sous bois alors que le maire les
services d'éducation et la préfecture
sous deux gouvernements différents s'y
sont opposés et là encore nous sommes
dans une prévision désormais non
seulement qui a été dépassé alors que le
maire s'y était opposé mais désormais
ces 4500 m² de surface plancher avec 510
élèves dans votre département
dans le département de seine-saint-denis
en l'occurrence donc il s'agit vraiment
de sujets très importants dont nous
pensions que le juge administratif à les
suivre l'avis des maires des
représentants de l'état et des
représentants de manière générale de
l'éducation nationale
vous évoquez madame la sénatrice alors
son comment ça va se faire
mais que fera le préfet grâce à sa
disposition il pourra soumettre à
l'autorité jeudi
l'autorité administrative pardon si
jamais cette décision était attaquée
c'est normal qu'elles soient attaqués si
on considère qu'elle est un excès de
pouvoir notamment des notes de
renseignement tout le monde l'acceptent
désormais dans l'instruction
administrative qui prouvent les a que
les intérêts de la nation et je
reviendrai sur la soie internationales
sont toujours dans cette question et la
dgsi traque fin les divers services de
renseignement peuvent nous démontrer
qu'il s'agit là d' ingérence étrangère
est manifestement de volonté de
séparatisme de la part du territoire
national et pardon monsieur le sénateur
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus
séparatiste
une école qui vise à construire les
enfants indépendamment son projet
pédagogique indépendamment de son projet
pédagogique contre ses propres valeurs
et ça n'a rien à voir avec les
dispositions du projet pédagogique parce
que voyez la difficulté c'est qu'il ya
soit parce qu'on a pratique de ce qu'on
appelle la taqiyya c'est bien la
dissimulation
en général on vient vous voir on
présente un projet qui apparaît à peu
près conforme et on sait tard soit il
faut que c'est là que c'est bien
différent de ce qu'on vous a vendue et
là pour le coup les autorités
préfectorales les maires pas chacun l'a
constaté quand on a dirigé déconnecté
des collectivités territoriales
s'aperçoit que c'est bien trop tard et
que le mal est largement fait et je
voudrais dire monsieur le monsieur
leleux sénateur qu'il s'agit pas
simplement de regarder conformément un
acte pas pédagogique il savoir s'agit de
savoir si on veut que des associations
dont on connaît les financements qui
s'opposent à un os valeur puisqu'il
refuse même de signer la charte
d'équivalent de respect des valeurs de
la république peuvent continuer à se
développer sur le territoire national la
réponse du gouvernement et non et comme
le juge administratif a manifestement
donné une interprétation qui est celle
sans doute de la loi aujourd'hui c'est
je crois le devoir du gouvernement est
donc du législateur de changer la loi
pour permettre aux juges de donner
raison aux locaux qui veulent combattre
ces ingérences parce que nous avons
discuté depuis le début de ce débat sur
qu'est-ce qu'on fait lorsque des élus
locaux peuvent de manière naïve de
manière calculée accepter une sorte de
communautarisme d'ingérence étrangère
là il s'agit pas de ça il s'agit des
locaux qui courageusement le refuse et
dont la justice de notre pays
en appliquant les lois de notre pays
considèrent qu'ils n'en parlent de s'y
opposer pardon de vous lire
une arme que l'on doit à ces élus qui
sont courageux s'agit pas de savoir si
poste politique
ils ont été ou pas courageux il a eu
nous demande d amm du courage je serai
bien piètre mise de l'intérieur si je ne
répondais pas à sète hérault
interrogations depuis le 9 le 9 avril
dernier
et puis je voudrais dire que la régime
autorisation préalable on peut en
discuter à l'infini
il a été souligné par votre chambre et
par celle de l'assemblée et par le
conseil d'état que ce n'était pas
constitutionnelle ont aussi ainsi si
monsieur le sénateur on peut le
regretter peut-être mais il s'agit de la
liberté une liberté fondamentale qu'est
liberté l'éducation là même qui vous a
poussé c'était très bien dit par le
président bas à refuser les dispositions
proposées par le gouvernement sur
l'instruction sur l'instruction en
famille
alors moi je vais vous dire très
franchement l'argument de monsieur sueur
et monsieur le comte pour dire il risque
d'y avoir des dvd comment dirais-je des
rétentions c'est un argument qui ne
tient pas la route dans ses cales
n'accepterions tout parce qu'un autre
pays pourrait avoir de rétention il ne
s'agit nullement de citer tel ou tel
pays et pardon de le dire monsieur
monsieur le sénateur bon jeudi pour le
milli gorus que je le dis bien
volontiers ce qu'on a bien que c'est
c'est là que se joue le jeu mais
peut-être que demain ce sera un autre
pays ou une autre un sens nous ne citons
pas un pays particulièrement c'est le
représentant de l'état français qui peut
s'opposer au nom de ses relations
internationales et contrairement à ce
que dit madame là
la sénatrice de la gontrie il s'agissait
nullement de faire fermer des écoles c
lire la suite ariane changer s'agit de
l'ouverture d'écoles sajid ouvertures
d'écoles
une fois que ces écoles sont ouvertes
vient l'autre moment quel ordre public
auquel projet pédagogique
là il s'agit de l'ouverture des écoles
alors connaissant ce que nous
connaissons à la fois par nourri par ses
débats par la décision du tribunal qui a
donné tort à la mairie d'albertville par
le fait que des élus locaux lé nous
demande d'être courageux par le fait
qu'il ya des associations très
clairement d'ingérence étrangère ou
islamistes qui mettent en péril la
république
non seulement ils le font mais ils le
font exodo en nous regardant les yeux
dans les yeux pour savoir sur va reculer
ben je pense que cet amendement
m'excusant de la difficulté peut-être de
le voir arrivé tardivement méritait de
ne pas laisser passer le train
législatif et jeudi où présent la
commission des lois que si en cmp le
sénat et l'assemblée souhaite trouver
les moyens d'être encore plus claire et
plus précis dans les buts que je viens
d'évoquer
c'est une bonne chose mais si nous
retirons les relations internationales
alors même la disposition des intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation ne permettrait
sans doute pas de s'opposer à
l'ouverture de l'école d'art ville
puisque il est évident que cette
ingérence
elle se fait subrepticement et que nous
avons des moyens a opposé au juge
administratif parce qu'il s'agit de
renseignements de précaution que nous
devons prendre et je pense que la
politique de la précaution elle voit
aussi contre l'islamisme radical et
quand les agences étrangères madame la
présidente rossignol c'est le ministre
vous mettez le sénat dans l'embarras
avec cet amendement mais parce que vous
y êtes vous même dans l'embarras
pourquoi on est dans l'embarras avec
votre amendement parce que pas parce
qu'ils arrivent en dernière minute on
est rompu à l'exercice et on est assez
souple pour examiner rapidement un
amendement mais parce que sa rédaction
nous paraît devoir être autant ri ça
risque de censure constitutionnelle que
la femme le fameux risque de censure que
vous brandissez quand il s'agit de
parler d'autorisation
parce qu'est ce que vous écrivez en fait
que le représentant de l'état le préfet
pourra former opposition c'est à dire
que le préfet examinera le projet
éducatif les financeurs tout ce qu'il ya
autour de cette ouverture déco leur
contrat et qu'il pourra donc décidé de
former opposition donc d'autoriser ou de
ne pas autoriser en réalité donc si
l'argument de l'inconstitutionnalité de
l'autorisation préalable que vous avez
brandi un instant est est solide ce que
je ne crois pas il est tout aussi solide
pour votre amendement qui est encore
plus discutable sur le plan juridique et
légistique parce qu'il n'est pas clair
je voudrais bien savoir comment le juge
administratif va se débrouiller des
relations internationales de la france
ou de ses intérêts c'est très compliqué
or nous voulons tous interdire les
autres les écoles hors contrats qui
portent atteinte aux intérêts de la
france qui favorise mollah radical
arrêtent des radicalités ou qui portent
atteinte aux intérêts des enfants nous
le voudrons tellement nouveau groupe
socialiste que nous avons proposé à
plusieurs reprises un amendement créant
une autorisation
parce que l'école d'albertville si on
avait voté l'autorisation préalable au
moment où nous avons dit c'est la loi
gatel mais vous l'auriez déjà utiliser
cette autorisation préalable mais
maintenant vous allez même pas pouvoir
utiliser cet article là pour albertville
puisque c'est pas rétroactif donc vous
êtes dans l'embarras monsieur le
ministre vous nous mettez vous nous il
était terriblement parce que nous
partageons vos intentions nous en avions
une meilleure solution juridique que la
vôtre et vous nous amenez maintenant à
devoir voter ou plutôt nous abstenir sur
un article dans la rédaction n'est pas
sérieuse monsieur le ministre
oui je regrette très profondément madame
la ministre rossignol que vous ne votez
pas d'amendement mais bien sûr la
liberté du vote s'exprime d'autant plus
que c'est un sujet je vous l'avais
difficile mais je peux pas laisser dire
les trois arguments que vous avez évoqué
d'abord vous dit tu es relations
internationales ça n'existe pas dans le
droit à jour envoie au céda qui est
truffé de relations internationales
jouent libaros l'article 321 1 du ceseda
prévoit qu'il est possible
pour le représentant de l'état de
prononcer une interdiction illustratif
de territoires qu un étranger dont la
présence constitue rénos grave pour les
relations internationales de la france
c'est un motif juridique que connaît le
droit des étrangers notamment c'est bien
logique puisque nous parlons la torah
lien avec des étrangers le deuxième
point là pour albertville ça
s'appliquera évidemment puisque ce café
albertville pour l'instant c'est une
opposition sur l'urbanisme et va venir
l'école last que nous faisons c'est que
nous nous opposons pas pour la
l'urbanisme mais bien pour l'ouverture
de l'école donc si cette disposition a
été votée
elles seraient prises pour albertville
ce qui est vrai c'est que
rétroactivement pour les dix écoles du
midi gruss il n'y a pas de possibilité
de fermeture par le préfet puisqu'elles
ont été ouvertes
l'agent tendance arguments et pour
albertville c'est le cas et 3 est bon je
ne souscris pas à votre argument sur
l'autorisation préalable puisque là il
s'agit de l'ouverture d'écoles sauf
opposition du préfet c'est autre chose
en droit d'avoir une généralité vous en
conviendrez
madame la ministre une généralité qui
vise à oui on peut ouvrir parce qu'ils
les libertés fondamentales
mais il ya des exceptions peut
l'affirmer et comment ça se passera j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire parce que d'un
point de vue de souvent été les services
de renseignement et c'est accepter par
la jurisprudence administrative depuis
désormais un certain temps puis se
produire des notes de la dgsi de drague
fin c'est le cas pour la révocation
fonctionnaires j'en ai moi même connu
même la gontrie qui permettent de
justifier après le juge
il permet de voir s'il ya un excès de
pouvoir ou non est par nature le le port
exécutif et celui à l'autorité
l'administratif du du juge donc il ya à
mon avis pas de pas de contradiction à
défend l'idée que c'est
inconstitutionnel comme l île conseil
d'état de prévoir une autorisation
préalable pour l'ouverture de l'école
mettrait avoir une exception qui
justement pour des raisons de
souveraineté d'intérêt fondamentales de
la nation nous permet de nous y opposer
merci monsieur le ministre j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe l'est républicain sur le
sous-amendement 692 je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission et du
gouvernement sont favorables il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert sur
l'amendement 692 compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au groupe
politique est notifiée à la présidence
nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 279 pour l'adoption
243 contre 36 le sénat a adopté
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public vers l'europe les républicains
sur l'amendement 691 avec un avis
favorable de la commission un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 110
sur l'amendement 691 compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs groupe
politique est notifiée à la présidence
nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 271 pour l'adoption
243 contre 28 le sénat a adopté
[Musique]